Hello Freak bitches. Yeah,
I didn't think of it at all.
That way it's out of the
podcast is just fun. Yeah,
just something to do for a goof.
And I did it for years,
like irregularly before I
ever won of committing to it.
But like every few weeks and then
palling around in the green room,
we would do in the green room and
Joey Diaz would always get mad.
Shut that fucking thing off.
You guys were always fucking online.
You're fucking around online. Shut it off.
Joe Rogan. He would get mad. I'd be like,
people like it.
You're wasting your fucking time on
the Internet. Yeah, I was relentless.
That's like the biggest
part of his lifetime now.
His podcast is gigantic for him. Yeah.
Yeah. He just did it the other night.
He was so high. He
fucking gave me the, he,
I forgot where his studio was, so I
said send me the address again. So we,
since we had dress, I fucking pull up
on this dark road and I go to, I go,
oh he wants to suck fucking switch the
studio or something cause this isn't the
old one. It's like, all right,
what the fuck? It's a house.
I guess he's doing it in the back of
his house. I fucking ring the doorbell.
It's his house. He was so high. He
gave me his fucking home address.
I'm texting him,
I'm out the front door and see a front
of the fucking streets and I walk in and
he's chewing down those.
What are they black start?
He's got a bong going. He's had
mushrooms. Least Siad is sitting there.
His eyes are shut. His eyes are shut.
I don't know how he sees you handle it.
I don't know how he does it.
Leaks. Lee can't handle it.
You could look in his eyes sometimes,
like I've been on the show before
and when someone says something,
I always feel like we're
having a conversation and
someone says something like,
well, what do you mean by that?
Yeah, and then we're having a talk,
but if you say like Lee said something,
I go, well what does that mean?
And he was like,
lock up.
Like it's just way too
high to have this path.
He was talking about how
he was like,
it seems like audio is the thing of the
future. I go, what? What do you mean?
He goes, well, it just seems like people,
like they're always on their phones
while they're on TV or they're watching a
movie,
they're talking on their phone or they're
looking through their phone or they're
listening to things while they're
doing other things. Like what?
I'll get you wait, you're listening
to things while you're watching TV.
You're Wa what?
Who the fuck was playing with their
phone while they're watching TV?
And he's like
fucking paranoid.
He'll wash over him like a tidal wave
of my area that we've just poor guy.
Well because two,
Hi Joey makes him do everything he does.
Not only Joey do that,
Joey's swaps edibles on them like lead,
try this.
It's only 50 milligrams and he'll take a
500 milligram pot and they'll put it in
the wrapper of a 50 and twist it back up.
It's mild cause mild like four of them.
And so it gives them enough to make
you reconsider your existence in the
universe while he's running.
The soundboard and he doesn't fuck up.
It's a good engineer. It's very
good. Yeah. Yeah. It's like,
I don't know if it's healthy to be
around Joey all the time like that.
Like he can be really danger. We'll
also Joey so good to him. You know,
they just have like a very,
very unique relationship man.
I mean that's a,
that's a God damn shell,
that relationship right
there because Joey's like a
father figure to him kind of.
Yeah.
And some insane way.
Joey's a sweetheart as long
as you're on his side. Yeah.
But the worst place in the world
is a guy who's against Joey.
Right? Like Joey's what the
worst I've seen like God,
Joey have feuds with people.
Hmm. It is a horrible thing to
watch. Yeah. You know, like he,
cause he's so passionate about his
friendship with people that when someone
turns on him, like he's the, as,
as loving and is friendly
and is warm as he is. Like,
you know how he is like when he
sees you it's all hugs and you know,
it calls you up because
you Greg Fitzsimmons what's
going on. Yeah. That's it.
You guys had a good Dick. Yeah.
What you're doing dog. You know,
and like he loves you. I
love Joey. Like, I mean,
he's my family like 100%
but if you turn on him,
man, it's a fucking horror. I've
seen him go after people. It's very,
yeah, it's crazy. He's so like he's Cuban.
Yeah. No. And you know, he came up,
he had a really fucked up
situation going on growing up his,
he found his mom dead when he was
13 he was on acid. Yeah. I mean,
so he was raised by his friends,
family sucking a tit that night to Waze.
Yeah,
he was sucking some girls tid on
acid. Oh, fun. Mom. Dad. Yeah.
Jesus was symbolism in that, huh? Oh,
marijuana sagging and tit was like, oh,
I don't need anything better than this.
I still,
it's still my wife.
Thank God I could not have married a
woman that didn't have a nice tits. Oh,
there's a lot of women out there with
little tits that are angry at you right
now. Sorry. You're not
real women. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
But I couldn't have married one.
I respect you and I'll hang out with
you. I'll let you into my shows. Wow.
But I'm not going to marry you.
Okay.